[Music]
well stock up on the noisemakers silly
hats and xanax the 2020 election is only
838 days away a new poll shows that
three out of four Democrats believe it's
time for a fresh face can you blame them
check out their ghosts of candidates
past Biden Hillary Bernie a cross
between the Three Stooges and cocoon the
only way to get out that vote is to
deliver walkers door-to-door while
yelling fire
Biden he thinks Amtrak is a success it
loses a billion a year
Hillary everyone loves a rematch but
everyone also loves a winner the only
thing she's one is ridicule it's less a
rematch and more a remake of Bride of
Chucky and Bernie a relic pushing
another relic called socialism he's
likable but his beliefs are toxic he's
like those delicious berries you pick
that poison your whole tribe and we
can't forget Liz can we but as someone
who is 2% Native American I have
reservations I do I could say that I'm
Native American part of me not sure what
part though so Tim's watch somebody knew
somebody different where could they have
learned this an Anthony Weiner did you
know that she's married to Anthony
Weiner you know the little thing being
Ben
I love you very much yep from the guy
they hate so much
that's the hypocrisy the people who
despise Trump are now looking for their
own Trump meaning a punk-rock outsider
who rejects the establishment and wins
why
perhaps we figured out that the worst
thing about politics are politicians and
if we learned anything from 2016 it's
that nothing will ever be the same you
can't go home again and if you're a
Democrat that includes retirement homes
so yep they need a new face especially
one that knows the issues my choice we
need to occupy every airport we to
occupy every border we need to occupy
every ice office until those kids are
back with their parents capitalism has
not always existed in the world and it
will not always exist in the world we
use the term the occupation of Palestine
mmm what did you mean by that
oh I think it what I meant is like the
the settlements I am NOT the expert on
geopolitics on this issue
trust me Democrats picker you will win
in a landslide
they might Dana you agree with me well
yeah I think that when the Democrats
every election is about new but this is
why you had hope and change yes right
and the Democrats did go with something
new in 2008 they rejected Hillary
Clinton and they nominated Barack Obama
to be their candidate and he was able to
win and then the Republicans go the
other way they're like okay but we're
gonna go with Trump so now the Democrats
are going to have probably 15 to 17
people on stage fighting it out over the
next I mean it's not far away the amid
the midterm election is November 6th the
2020 general election starts November
7th right so if you really are going to
start seeing a lot more of this and I
don't think that necessarily she would
win at this time around but the left
it's becoming more progressive they want
somebody new and different somebody
who's willing to fight even if it's
futile right for example in the Supreme
Court nomination of Dan Pfeiffer who was
the former communications director for
Obama he's out on his book tour now and
he says even though we know
we're probably going to lose is worth
fighting yeah
fighting to the death like well you
might just fight to the death yeah it's
like when you're arguing with the spouse
right just stop yeah you won welcome
back you did a great job at the all-star
game I think I have to defend Alexandria
most people don't know how to explain
the Middle East no especially if you're
28 and yes I mean she's a newcomer into
the political stage and forget the
geopolitical stage she's never been on
it yeah I don't think she's gotten there
yet but I think you're exactly right
that people want a new face and it's not
only that they want a new face that's
interesting I saw in the polls that
there's a split between people who voted
for Hillary as to whether or not they
would even take a Hillary back now I
think where the argument you get Greg is
from the Bernie supporters right who see
him as Cortes same thing more energy and
here's one thing I noticed in the in the
in the research Democratic strategist
saying we want somebody who will punch
Trump in the face right so they want
someone who plays like Trump who's
bullying has the kind of red arrow I
think an actor a celebrity Yeah right
somebody who brings name ID to the table
has pockets of their own money and
challenges the party's base that's
mm-hmm sounds like your guys candidate
yes there you go all right Jesse I like
the idea of a rematch the reason why I
don't think Hillary wants to be forever
known as the person who lost a Trump
that's gonna be the first line in the
obituary not that she was Secretary of
State but that she lost a trump twice
what that would be a great listen to a
lot of kind of mediocre and preposterous
monologues but I think that was very
good almost as if I wrote it myself no I
think the Democrats need the nominative
fresh face it I'm going to be
contributing to the campaign coffers
yeah of this little Socialist Cortes
whatever her name is but the Democrats
are right when they pull this they want
a fresh face they win with fresh faces
they win with Bill Clinton they will
with Barack Obama and they lose with
gore and
carry on Hillary so like you said they
want someone that's going to punch Trump
square in the face and they don't want
to do this Michelle Obama thing where
you know Trump goes low we go high
they're ready to get in the mud but
there's problems with that the only
person I can see really going toe-to-toe
with him verbally is Biden and I would
not call Biden a fresh face also when
you get in the mud with Donald Trump you
never really get out he's a brawler and
he wins ugly we're gonna get to Rubio
and also it doesn't set up a contrast a
mini Trump and I think you win when you
set up a nice contrast but it they're
having a civil war and the energy and
the idealism is on the far left and the
money and the practicality is more
towards the center and we're going to
watch this thing and it's going to be
great to watch but the media is going to
cover up all this internal friction and
that's going to be to the detriment of
the Democratic Party what's interesting
too because to Dana's point Democrats
used to be really good it's sort of
stifling primaries and clearing them out
and now they're not as much because you
have this progressive wing of the party
that is super charged up we've seen that
coming to fruition this primary serious
primary time where we we haven't really
seen that before but I think the bigger
problem for Democrats is President Obama
had really focused on identity politics
for eight years and with that you saw an
airing a narrowing of the Democratic
Party Republicans are able to take
advantage of that during the midterm
elections and president Trump was as
well of being able to pick up these
Democrat strongholds that hadn't gone
for Republicans and quite some time so I
think this push to the left focusing on
things like abolishing I only further
narrows the party which hurts them and
is a negative impact heading into 2020
well you know that's the point actually
one is like and we talked about this
about how Trump wasn't an ideologue he
was some I mean he these are some of
these stances he had were liberal some
of them were definitely not Republican
what if should the Dems be focusing on
somebody who is not an ideological
Democrat I don't know I don't know how
we would define an ideological Democrat
on the Left I'm not sure communist okay
[Applause]
you know what I think that was
interesting it I think the counter to
Trump maybe a woman who do you want to
see a young woman not unlike that Donna
no no I think a young energetic woman
who is unapologetic and saying you know
what yep I think I should have health
care in this country yep I think that we
should raise the minimum wage yeah I
think that we should have no more
student debt for people who are trying
to get an education is this Li that's
pretty strong well she's one of them but
I think she's too in experiences yeah
how old is she don't have to be 35 28
right yeah yeah you got a president yet
yeah yeah yeah that eliminates me too
you know yes this contrast thing large
number of Democrat Republican candidates
that looked alike made Trump stand out
we've talked about that so I think
you're gonna end up with a Democrat that
stands out right because a lot of the of
the 15 possible Democrats a lot of them
are senators right okay and it's hard to
run from the Senate especially well
Obama did it but I think McCain and
Hillary Clinton showed that it's really
hard okay I carry as well so yeah I have
to surprise that his name hasn't
surfaced a little bit more he has a book
coming out September 24th so you might
want to add anything you see you you
planted the seed without Frankie look
what happened with that what's
interesting is President Trump will have
a record to run on and he will be a
known entity to Republicans he's got
right now and ninety percent approval
rating amongst Republicans so he's
running so low and he has a record to
run on in a good economy then you have
this massive primary we're really only
twenty percent of the country is saying
okay we are really far left 20 percent
are saying they're really far right now
you see in some surveys 60 percent of
Americans are saying I'm independent so
what happens if in the primary you go so
far left to me that gives President
Trump a pretty good opening to walk
right back in and also here's where I
just think the Democrats face their
hardest challenge when the tea party was
ignited it was based off of Paul
see it was based off of bailouts and
Obamacare and spending and they had
these great rallies where they cleaned
up after themselves yes and they had
speakers and then they translated that
into winning back the house and they did
all right in the Senate they kind of cut
their nose off to spite their face a few
times but it translated into electoral
success the Democrats energy I wouldn't
call it at the level of a tea party I
mean right now they have small rallies
there's no great speaker and their basic
messages I hate Trump it's not really
around a policy and the policy that it
is around is either abolish ice or we
want socialism and their tactics have
backfired chasing people out of
restaurants yelling horrible things at
people I just don't know if they're
ready for primetime in terms of fielding
good candidates to take back the house
and that's also when you have a crowded
primary field you can see a lot of these
people that are being discussed like a
Kamala Harris a Cory Booker they all
kind of occupy the same space you could
inevitably see someone come down the
middle like Trump did president Trump
did that nobody saw coming struck I
think I think the one thing that's not
in equation is you draw on it is the
tremendous energy on the left because of
Trump and I think that now extends to
the middle you see that in the polls
Jesse the intensity on the Left going
into the midterms far exceeds what
you're seeing on the right even with
something like Cavanaugh and certainly
when it comes to taxes I don't know what
the Republican message is other than we
don't like immigrants jobs Eko walnuts
winning the truth can be cheap get it I
said it's 838 days away it's actually
about I mean 20 where are we now 28 2019
is where it's gonna start it's kind of
scary that it is